the main topic of this conversation is a
project that I've been working on for
the past few months is this particular
project that is real-time news
clustering to understand news events as
they're occurring for that let's go back
in time a little bit when I was at
school I was studying physics of MRI and
employing spatial temporal such as the
called noise reduction techniques to
combine them with physiological modeling
to understand blood volume in different
parts of the brain the dimensionality of
the data that I was working in why you
was 256 pixels by 256 pix so in the XY
plane along the z axis about 10 to 12
slices and temporal dimension was 6
minutes about 360 seconds so that's 10
to the power of 6 and we thought that
big data back turn we don't look some
nice model for that and when I joined
Charpy I thought oh I couldn't play a
lot of these models statistical
techniques and I could help publishers
understand their readers better but I
noticed that the scale of the data
Charpy trenders all my models prohibited
basically and what I've been spending my
time during the past year and a half is
thinking about how to bring the
computational CS computational
scalability to statistical techniques
that focus on accuracy and performance
of your model
traditionally in statistics you have a
cost function that you're trying to
minimize as the number of data grows the
number of data the size of the data is a
source of simplicity and as it grows you
can invoke asymptotic results and the
quality of your inference improves in CS
I think the size of the data is
source of complexity something you have
to tame with computation and hardware
and I've been thinking a lot about how I
can blend these two techniques together
these approaches together sorry I have
to use my notes so that's that let me
give you a brief overview about chart B
we worked with a lot of publishers as I
say we helped them track their traffic's
on the website and how it works is that
each publisher puts our JavaScript code
on their website then in the readers
browser that codes continually sends a
stream of things to us and those pings
let's say if I used to go to doctors
website back in the days those pings are
like image requests and the data is URL
encoded in them and we receive those
pings we aggregate them analyze them and
give publishers some information about
the state of their website and how many
people are on there what they're reading
where they're coming from
think about an editor in your favorite
daily newspaper they have so many
choices that they have to make during
today from what content to promote on
the website where to put it what you
wrote on Facebook Twitter and with this
data with what we do we give them some
context into how their readers are
interacting with their content on the
web so it makes that decision-making
process for them a bit easier the scale
of the data at peak per day basis is 1.5
billion
per day and it comes from 50,000
different publishers a lot of them are
non-english publishers a lot of them are
English publishers 40 to 80 thousand new
English documents per day get published
and we track them and this is a
breakdown on an hourly basis as they
come in so weekends less during weekdays
more publications as expected and these
are the documents that we will go about
clustering them real time as they're
happening as we're scraping them okay so
how can we go about this how can we
prove them as they're being published a
lot of people have been talking about it
thinking about it take Google for
example as you see each one of those is
a group of like articles about the same
news event Twitter moments has Google
does it completely algorithmically
Twitter human SSL algorithms and each
one of those again is a collection of
similar tweets about the same event
Facebook trending they used to use human
editors to curate these lists but now
they're just using keyboards named
entities to come up with the list of
like Facebook posts about that same
entity but at the gist of it it's you
want to group things that are about the
same thing and different from other
things that are in different groups how
you go about it is you have to have a
mathematical abstract way to represent
your objects articles in this
so you have to embed them in a feature
space what is that feature space what
are the features you can wait your
features differently we'll talk about
that some maybe contribute more to the
separation of the clusters some
contribute less and the gist of every
clustering classification dimensionality
reduction is you have to have a way to
measure a distance between two objects
so how do you measure that distance as
for the computational challenges as I
told you size of the data is huge and
the real-time nature of it adds a lot of
computational complexity we'll talk
about all of them it's not that these
are two separate category of problems
the computational restrictions bear on
the statistical approaches that you can
use likewise it's like a trade-off
between your cost function the accuracy
of your algorithm and the runtime and
complexity of the algorithm so you have
to see where in that trade-off you want
to be and let's go on okay so let's say
you find a way to embed your articles in
some feature space you can use words
I'll talk about this in detail later but
let's say for now you can use all the
words in a document each word will be a
dimension in your feature space and the
weight of these feature dimensions
dictate where your articles lie in that
space let's say we've done that then we
can go back to clustering them the
textbook clustering algorithm you have
endpoint in a P dimensional feature
space you want to come up with K
clusters
each cluster cluster K has let's say NK
documents in it or objects in it the
cost function that you're minimizing in
that situation is the within cluster sum
of distances so given that you want to
partition everything into K clusters you
want to come up with the partition that
minimizes the waiting cluster some of
these senses first of all you have to
calculate the pairwise distances between
any two points and that's the order of P
N squared it's not exponential so it's
not that bad but still it's expensive
for real-time applications it's
expensive then you have to come up with
all these different partitioning of your
points and find the best one that
minimizes the cost function the number
of those partitions grows with K and n
just to make it tangible if you have 25
points you want to cluster them into 4
clusters that's going to be about 5 to
the 10 to the power of 13 clusters I
just off the top of my mind
know
so it's so expensive I mean you can do
that even in the batch sitting here let
alone real-time questing you have to
solve it by approximations and you have
to be content without stop optimal
solution solve it iteratively like in
k-means and all the clustering
algorithms for real-time application the
problems as we talked about that's for
back to sitting not real-time in the
real-time case scenario you have new
documents coming in do you have to
calculate the pairwise distance of the
new documents with all the documents
that you've already clustered so far so
many documents like how far back in time
do you go it's going to be huge eighty
thousand documents a day and if you want
to consider the last week it's going to
be about five hundred thousand two weeks
a million documents you have and they
keep coming in so adds to the
computational complexity and another
thing for this particular application
use real-time news clustering like the
whole rationale is that you want to be
able to pick up new news events as
they're happening so that means the
number of your clusters is increasing
with time so you can come up with an
approximation of the algorithm that I
just talked about first so you don't
have to compute the pairwise distances
of a new point with all the points that
are in your previous Buster's let's
represent each cluster with one central
point and that is n 4 plus ok and when
you have a new document just calculate
the pairwise distances with that Center
cluster Center and let's say you have to
allow creation of new clusters right
let's say if the distance of my new
document to the closest cluster is
higher than a certain threshold that you
have to tune depending on
granularity of the clusters that you
want so if the distance from the closest
cluster Center is higher than a certain
threshold this new document becomes the
first element the first article in a new
news cluster if not you join it to the
closest cluster Center so good we did we
made some improvements now in
calculating the pairwise distances we
reduce that from PN Square to pk but
still as I said this K the number of
clusters growing with time and your
lookup time will keep growing and
growing so let's assume that we've
implemented a clustering and we're
detecting new clusters as they're
occurring in time this is number in an
hourly basis as you see this is how news
stories are they grow with time how can
we solve that problem one way of doing
that is just again the context of this
problem gives us a solution think about
news stories they don't need long
lifetime of news stories is limited
FBI email scandal with Clinton that's
going to live a long time but there will
be new developments through its lifetime
and those maybe deserve to have their
own clusters so this is let's say this
is an algorithm that I've been playing
the chart beat and I take a bunch of
clusters and I look at them add a sixth
since their inception right and I look
back in time and I say okay the total
number of articles that were in each
cluster how what fraction of them were
added on day one day two day three day
four and a-five this will give me an
idea of at what rate articles get added
or people write about that story
on a daily basis and you see usually
maybe the average lifetime is around two
to three four days and what this helps
you how this helps you is that you can
say okay when I'm measuring the distance
of my do document to my previous
clusters I'm just going to limit myself
to story clusters of the last week and
that's it or six days or five days okay
so you're somehow bounding K the number
of clusters in that pairwise distance
calculations but another issue again is
that as a new as in news cluster is
evolving it gradually changes you want
to be able to capture the gradual
changes not the macro changes that maybe
don't deserve another cluster what do
you want to be able to capture the
gradual changes and how you would do
that you want your cluster Center to
reflect those incremental changes you
can't when you're adding a new document
or a cluster you can pull all the
previous documents in that cluster and
find a cluster Center again ideally you
would like to have a way to
incrementally update your cluster Center
because you see some of these clusters
have a lot of pages in them and again
lookup time is high your memory
limitations all those things are
considerations so best solution is to
incrementally update your clusters let's
say you're you've added your end new
document xn to this cluster you update
your old cluster using a learning rate
that is there should be subscript okay
over there yes so you let this learning
rate drop and decrease as new articles
are being added to the cluster but the
rationale that you want an story cluster
to solidify around that story
you don't want to let it grow
indefinitely so this way it helps with
if an new document appeared that's
similar to this but not quite and it
deserves a new cluster you want and for
some reason it goes into that cluster
you don't change the cluster Center it
drastically change you'll keep it in
place okay so these updates are
important
another issue is again the nature of the
news how we write about things at
sometimes we've noticed that some Surry
clusters some two different story
clusters sorry articles about the same
story start on different tracks as an
example the Wiener FBI investigation
into weiners emails was very different
than FBI investigation into Clinton's
emails but at some point in time they
became very different to separate very
very difficult to separate and you
wouldn't it wasn't easy to say are those
different clusters are they the same
basically you want to add this level of
flexibility that if the cluster centers
started moving close to each other you
have this option of merging them okay
that adds to the quality of your
clustering a lot of what I talked about
so far was about computational
considerations slightly some about the
quality of clustering but we're gonna
get into the statistics of it I deal
with accuracy of your clusters now so as
I said first step to go about your
clustering is to embed your documents
objects in a mathematical space
and the choice of these features
determine the granularity of the
clusters that you will have let's take
that example okay and one way to define
your features is you take all the tokens
with the exception of stop words and
whatnot you Lema ties them and you can
take all the tokens you can get more
details and just take named entities
that will give you a clustering that
looks more like Facebook's result more
coarse clusters that doesn't capture the
nuances around coverage of a named
entity the nuances around the coverage
of Anthony Weiner scandal or Clinton
scandal if you want to get those nuances
and you want your clusters to be more
granular maybe you should focus on nouns
or even better on noun phrases that are
parts of speech that accompany nouns so
it's adjective and noun and any other
part of speech that comes attached with
the noun and you break I chose to use
noun phrases and I break them into
tokens because assume an article has
Barrack Obama and Obama and Barack and
each of these would give you three
different dimensions in your future
space there's so much redundancy but if
you break them into tokens just get
Barack and Obama you've reduced that
three to two but you're also keeping
preserving the synergy so yes you can
focus on noun phrase tokens that will
give you more granular clusters compared
to named entities and probably have less
noise compared to when you're using all
your tokens that makes your feature
selection step easier if you're using
noun phrase tokens compared to all
tokens I mean you can get more
complicated depending on your particular
application you can use subject verb
object combinations or you can use
neural network techniques talk to awake
or average War Tuvok for an article and
that's how you would embed your
documents and you
space but anyways choice of future space
dictates the quality of your clusters
the granularity and it's very important
I want to point out to this library that
was developed by Burton a colleague of
mine at chart beat it's a general NLP
text processing and analysis library it
lets you scale ibly extract all these
now and calculate the distances between
documents different distance metrics and
so many other options that you have you
should check it out and we use that at
sharpie so another thing that influences
the quality of your product at the end
of the day real time use clustering
again you want to be able to pick up new
events as they're happening and as I
said we're using noun phrases with this
rationale that a lot of the news events
are about nouns issues or nouns names of
people and things of places
organizations all nouns right and with
nouns you have this complexity that
there will be new nouns that you don't
have it in your vocabulary at the time
that you build your feature space what
you want to definitely allow away a
flexible way so that your feature space
can grow like when the volcano happened
in Iceland do you remember what it was
called
yes so when it happened in Iceland we
probably didn't have that word in our
vocabulary so one way of doing that is
that allow a larger feature space higher
dimensionality which has a couple of
thousand or tens of thousands of empty
dimensions and fill them up as new words
are appearing or new features are
appearing so you can extend your
vocabulary okay so I mean for now the
dimensionality of our feature space is
around 1 million and 500,000 that's a
lot that's a lot and so that's P and
when you're calculating the distance
pairwise distances and whatnot those
things scale with P you want to have a
way to select which features are more
important for your clustering not all
features contribute equally to
separation of your clusters right
and again News is about something new it
doesn't mean that the less frequently
used features are the ones that you
should discard and ignore actually those
are chances are high are the most
important features that you want to keep
and usually in NLP what people do is
that they trim off two ends of the
spectrum the tokens that are here too
frequently and the tokens that appear
the least frequently right and that's
not what we want to do we want to have
some smarter way of selecting these
features and just some numbers just to
give you an idea so average unique non
praise tokens per article is about four
and I said the dimensionality of our
feature space is 1 million and 500,000
and average unique now free tokens that
are used daily is about 200,000 so it's
a good case for feature selection right
so we can get
complicated as we want and one way of
doing that is way to your features so
when you're calculating your pairwise
distances just put a higher weight on
dimensions that contribute more to the
separations of your clusters as I said
and WJ is the weight that you put a long
dimension feature dimension J how you
cancel it that is that you measure the
distance between clusters as an
approximation for that you can use the
cluster centers and measure the
distances take the averages along each
feature dimensions and see and and and
then you would soft tresh hold whatever
you get
it's like sparse clustering any convex
optimization problem that has some
sparse penalization is going to have
soft tresh holding one way or another as
its solution so you software shoot those
a J's and lambda is your tuning
parameter that determines how sparse you
want the selected the number of selected
features will be if your lambda is too
much your weight vector will be more
sparse that means your algorithm
determines oh there are less important
features if your lambda is higher your
so if your lambda is lower your solution
will be less sparse so you're using more
of your features in calculating the
distances yes basically I mean I'm
adding more and more parameters to tune
but we'll talk about that so that's how
you get your future weight I haven't
talked about my distance matrix that
much okay let's talk about that so when
you're making that decision you remember
we had a trash hold we have a new
document
we have all those clusters we have a
Trish hold and we say if my dude my new
document' is close enough to this
cluster put it in that cluster if not it
becomes its own cluster now when you're
comparing different clusters with each
other and let's say that's a new article
and these are two different clusters
that represents the center of that
cluster that one in the center of the
other cluster as you see this cluster
has a higher reaching cluster scatter
which is the average of this sense of
all the points from its center that one
is a tighter much tighter cluster as an
example I can tell you from experience
that a lot of the political campaign
Hillary and Trump's coverage are just so
scattered drained just all over the
place and so it's very difficult but but
a particular issue but particular set of
news that are maybe talking about their
attitudes towards NRA that deserves to
be a much tighter cluster and somehow if
you have an article that's in between
that fits in the cluster scatter of your
larger cluster maybe it should go there
so you should somehow scale the
difference of the distance with the
cluster scatter and so this circle
represents that cluster scatter it's
uniform in all dimensions but that's not
actually the case these clusters have
shapes as you see that within average
you know clusters scattered that circle
doesn't capture the shape of the cluster
so in this situation where the new
document lies you know more along the
principal axis of the blue cluster
compared to the green cluster and
probably it seems like that's a better
choice but if you look at the centroid
the cluster centers that's parlor this
is closer and if you scale with this
with you cluster scatter it's too much
along this dimension it shouldn't be
that type so you want to use you want to
use something to scale the distances and
there's something should capture it
cluster scale and shape at the same time
basically you want a higher distance
along a dimension with higher variation
to count less than a small distance
along a dimension with lower variation
that's your figure you want to capture
closer covariance or just the covariance
matrix of a bunch of points is is what
can capture both clusters scale and
shape at the same time but how to
estimate it to come up with your sample
covariance matrix here we're in a
dangerous regime the average number of
articles per cluster is about ten the
dimensionality of the feature space or
there are millions as I told you and
this renders estimating coming up with a
good sample covariance not feasible
there has been a lot of research done in
that area people have had solutions like
you can assume your covariance matrix or
the inverse of it has a particular
structure it's diagonal low rank or it's
dense and sparse and low rank and but
they're good a lot of them are good for
when your data is dense or their
computationally infeasible for real-time
applications what you can do a simple
way that I can come up with
to just calculate that cluster variation
in a direction that's relevant to your
new document I'm not saying this is the
best solution whatever solution that
people will come up with will include
this intuition for sure but this is a
good intuitive way of coming going
around the problem of estimating and
coming up with your sample covariance
matrix but so yes anyways what you can
do is that project each point along this
you know relevant direction and get the
variance of those and that's what you
use to scale your distance from the new
point and cluster centers okay so let's
say we did all of this things and let's
say we came up with our clusters there's
a lot of subjectivity that goes in there
like how how do you tune all your hyper
parameters that you had and I told you
like your feature selection your
distance metric selection all those
things have bearings on the quality of
clusterings and also the granularity
it's very difficult if you take four
people in this crowd and asked them to
cluster stories about where I can match
you will this be the same hierarchy that
you will come up with and I doubt it I
don't know a lot of you may disagree
with what I have here but when it's
difficult for a human mind to come up
with a canonical way to cluster the news
articles we can't expect our algorithms
to do that you have to accept that a big
part of the problem is subjective at the
end of the day it has to look good for
in the eyes of who's using the product
the editors and you can get bogged down
in coming up with metrics or algorithms
to estimate the hyperparameters
automatically but I think in doing that
you who lose part of the truth
at the end of the day and that is that
internet content is the vomit of human
consciousness it's it's very difficult
to clustered and pacify them group them
together in a coherent way in an optimal
way and I think we must not expect more
precision that what the subject matter
pyramids from I don't know how many
centuries ago still stands today and
with that that's me that's my Twitter I
don't put anything data science related
on there but I don't know if you want to
check it you can check it and hopefully
are no questions no please ask me if you
have any questions
[Applause]
just repeat the questions for the night
we can take a few questions before she
goes down for office hours she'll be
just downstairs for a little bit so if
anyone has questions raise your hand
I'll take the mic over to you
can an article be part of multiple
clusters like more than one cluster can
an article be part of more phosphorus so
I mean you know I I just talked about it
so it's a fuzzy kind of logic that we're
trying to get at it suppose a kind of
wisdom that we're aiming for right and
if you employ probably the sake
approaches that captures that effect
that you want an article can be part of
different clusters in a probabilistic
way but you know the scalability
constraints become bigger in real time
passions for this kind of applications
it's a step in the right direction but I
don't we're not still there for us to be
able to use it for this scale of the
data that we're dealing with and at the
rate at which they're coming in yeah yes
I have a question regarding the lifetime
of the cluster how did you measure the
lifetime of cluster are you sure the yes
the graph so
I had some clusters
a couple thousand of them and I looked
at them at day six from their inception
so I aligned you know their start time
all of them they want to treat they six
each of them has you know some number of
articles in them then I looked back in
time day one how many of you know the
total number of articles on day six were
added on the first day how many on the
second day how many on the third day I
took the fraction with respect to you
know how many articles were in each
cluster so I had a bar part and I looked
at the median of those and this shows
you the median of those clusters it's I
was surprised when I saw this because I
would imagine that a lot of the articles
a lot of the clusters will get populated
I got the first and second day and they
slowly drop in time but that was not the
case it probably has to do with
clustered granularity maybe maybe if I
made them more specific the clusters are
more granular I would see something like
an exponential drop but it's somewhere
in the middle the granularity maybe when
a new news event happens and people are
writing about it it instigates more in
depth you know investigation of the
piece and more pieces coming in on the
third or fourth day not sure but that's
a question
how to count the number of articles
[Music]
maybe develop some article is kind of
indirect Fitz you might miss you didn't
count maybe if it wasn't clustered
correctly right cluster isn't it's not
it's maybe I could also other cluster
but it's actual meaning is actually in
this cluster for example yes so I I
think this was based on five thousand
clusters and I invited I don't know a
couple of hundred of them by I make sure
the all the articles that are in the
clusters are about actually the same
event and it was okay I had to discard
some clusters that were like the
political you know coverage of the
campaign's they're not so tight they're
just all over the place so I had to
discard things like that and I'm not
showing you debar plots here so I'm
cheating a little bit the force clusters
like hurricane Matthew those are two
clusters that keep living for a long
time and they were contributing to you
know the error bar on the positive side
to be larger but again as I argued maybe
if a new story lasts that long
hurricane Matthew maybe you want a
different cluster for when it's in the
Caribbean and when it hits Florida then
when it hit South Carolina you know
[Music]